why do those shorts cover your
bellybutton but not your balls what's
that on your face it looks like you
drank a glass of Ed Sheeran's pubes dogs
ready to you Jeremy said we're going
like six miles into the woods nature's
great nah but it's still spring break
and I'm ready to rage Donnie
drink up [ __ ] oh this knife is so sharp
it can cut piss
Oh No I think I cut myself
[Applause]
number one I have a medical emergency I
need a medevac pronto you get a say John
lost all the phones where's Mike Ditka
now my seven shirts will get their
attention 12 hours a severed member
could still be reattached yeah whose
idea was it to set off the fire ball was
all me did your [ __ ] idiot
you gave the EMT the wrong cooler
don't you yell at me I'm not the one who
got drunken obviously you don't have a
dick no one in this room has a dick yeah
oh my god dick we have to get the venom
out how do we do that
someone has to suck it up suck it
I will suck the dick it's really cool of
you yeah you too man
[Music]
cooler is not the penis also it got bit
by a snake I sucked it pretty good I'm
getting a lot of venom out of this thing
surgery went perfectly
oh my god there's something that you
should know where did they find this
thing a little Navajo boy
[Music]
you